My tumor markers were never out of range even when I had two
letters before double mastectomy was done in September 2023.
Recently, I have had an increase that outside normal, but moving
to the wrong direction.
Since 2024, September 24, taking Dr.
Chiefs are meant to stop reoccurrence and metastasis.
Could these have caused the tumor markers to fluctuate, like chemo does sometimes?
I don't always get to the lab company, same lab company,
unfortunately, and here's the comparison last one since you gave us.
No, I don't think that the products would cause
the tumor markers to fluctuate, like chemo does.
So, chemo causes tumor markers to fluctuate,
typically because it's killing cancer cells through the process of cell
lysis versus apoptosis.
And you'll, through cell lysis, you are liberating
everything inside the cell, including that you're called endotoxins,
and you are causing more issues, as far as spilling
two marker proteins, possibly.
So, no, I don't think Dr.
Chiefs products would change the tumor marker test.
You just did a cheek swab for me this week, and I sent you the entire comparison.
Grid, I don't know if you referenced it before you began,
the only things different are the Dr. Chiefs supplements and my diagnosis for a couple of months.
I just don't know what to do next about this, if anything,
but you do a cheek swab, and there are differences,
Koida, do you just check the previous supplements,
or do you check to see if I did other things?
So, I check to see if you need other things too.
So, I don't remember if any additions came up on you.
But it's not uncommon that we have an addition, because I'm checking other things.
That may have tested since the beginning, because
something may have changed.
So, no, there was a deity additions on you, just that thing else tested for that.
So, you don't need to worry about adding anything.